hi i'm grant petty i'm the ceo of
blackmagic design and we make video
products for film and television
industries so we do pretty much
everything we even do cameras and
davinci resolve which is a high-end
color grading system for film and
television so we really have a wide
range of products and you know we've
sell over million products a year
[Music]
[Music]
i grew up in a country town in
regional victoria
and i was in a underprivileged area so
the school would get grants occasionally
for things and they had a grant for a
full room of apple ii computers that
showed their online and
that also actually had a tv issue which
had been put in years earlier so we used
to spend all that time in the tv studio
trying all these different things and
doing some of the worst videos around
but we just had a lot of chance to play
we'd go in even before school we'd go
and we'd stay back after school we made
friends with the cleaners and then i got
some work experience at the local tv
station and the radio station the tv
station was a shock because the
technology was complicated and i
remember looking at the monitor
and one of the engineers was explaining
something to me and i remember just it
hit me this industry is never going to
get boring i mean i remember just
hitting me like this is it this is what
i want to do because i'd already been
doing it at school and then i got a job
in post-production which is kind of the
part of production where they do all the
editing and the color correction all
kinds of stuff so i started working in
that but the thing that shocked me was
how incredibly expensive the equipment
was because i have a million dollars
easily for the smallest thing it hit me
one day the publishing industry actually
had a lot of software
and they were doing the same kind of
work we were doing they're doing color
correction and all these things fashion
shoots and all these magazines i thought
if i could get that software to work in
television it would change the industry
completely and it would make it much
more affordable so more people could do
it and so that was kind of the start of
doing like our original products with
capture cards and then we moved on to
other things we've had seven
acquisitions we've actually done as well
and we've improved those products like
we've got bought davinci which is a
high-end hollywood color correction
system and we bought the switcher
products which is used for live sports
you know we're live switching between
cameras and all this sort of stuff and
we've completely revamped those products
we introduced a range of digital film
cameras that were affordable so it's
just been this weird journey where you
just sort of take opportunity after
opportunity you try to be as good as you
can and then when those opportunities
pop up it leads you to the next step and
we're here now so it's kind of a long
journey but it's been exciting
originally we found davinci was for sale
because we actually had a
post-production company
we had one in singapore because you know
initially the idea of it was actually to
test our equipment if we had a
post-production company we'd be able to
install our own equipment in it see how
it worked get the feedback we ended up
doing a deal with them to buy it and
then
got to work at really rebuilding it when
we bought davinci they were delivering
literally all the computers the monitors
a lot like it was just insane like that
was how things were sold they had sales
guys who sold these massive systems or
over a million dollars you know da vinci
was 350 000 for the simplest one eight
hundred thousand dollars for the top one
that was used on film so my thinking was
if we could get computers to do that
work that would be a good thing and we
had some interesting tricks on how we
did it like we used the computer to do a
lot of the work that normally be on
hardware so the heart was as simple as
it possibly could be and now the
question is why is it free our thinking
was that we need the tv industry should
have its own product we shouldn't just
let the computer guys take it the
problem is is that people in the
computer industry are moving to
subscription software and you see it
almost used everywhere now in fact you
pretty much can't get venture capital
now all the vc's care about is how many
subscriptions you're getting what's the
rate of adoption of subscribers you know
it doesn't have to make any money
because you know if you get subscribers
you can have them for decades
i don't like subscription software from
that point of view the red line that i
can't cross is tying people's work up
unless they keep paying every month that
feels like a mafia style you know
payoffs to keep your business running it
just doesn't feel good at all and the
very core of everything blackmagic does
every decision we make
is to make our customers more free
creatively free
you know it's empowering the creative
freedom that's the core of what we do
so you don't empower their creative
freedom if you lock their work up in a
tool i thought if we made it for free
and everyone could just download it and
use it it would create a large market
then some of that proportion of those
customers will then buy it when they
start to make money so our job is to
trick our customers into being
financially successful the way we
actually make money is we sell control
panels like big color correction panels
and
and capture cards and a whole bunch of
different products that you know that
work with davinci editor keyboards and
things like that if you get good enough
you start sort of wanting some of those
things and then as you start to succeed
move up the scale and then we start to
get some payback it's a long-term
investment but it's not a mafia style
shakedown of 20 a month or 30 or
whatever these things cost just because
it's not popular and everyone doesn't do
it it doesn't mean to say it's not the
right business model
[Music]
the whole company focused on their first
camera and it was the most minimal
camera you could get people joked and
said it was a fisher-price camera and
they completely misunderstood why we
were building it we had da vinci and
then the problem is all the cameras just
shot video and they clipped the whites
and they cooked the blacks and there was
no range and there was nothing to color
grade but if you can't shoot in digital
film because the cameras cost 100 grand
or 80 grand or whatever then you've got
no hope of bringing more colors and even
if the software doesn't cost anything
you still can't really do it because
they just can't succeed so we did all
the things that kind of mattered but it
was just the most paired down camera you
could possibly get but that was the
point the people that understood it they
saw what it was so while everyone joked
and laughed at it the reality is that
people understood and the ones that had
the most desperate need realized what it
was and then bought it so it sold quite
well because we were delivering a
solution to something that didn't exist
we never had venture capital because
nobody would fund this i mean no one
funds a change in the industry they fund
something that's predictable because who
would give this guy he's got no
experience no skill no education in
business no understanding of anything
and he's trying to make a product
that no one's asking for it so we could
never get any money from anywhere so we
just had to sell fund it which meant she
did whatever it took to get a product to
market
so one of the advantages i think that
entrepreneurs don't understand their
strength is if you come from a poor
background or even an industry outside
the industry you're trying to fix you
don't know anything right i have no idea
what i was doing because if you know
what you're doing then you're not baking
anything that's pushing yourself so it
means you can kind of move in unique and
new ways and find information and really
look around to see what kind of like
what is black magic culture it's
whatever we made it to be to succeed
it wasn't planned it wasn't defined by
anyone it was just what we ended up
creating to do what we're doing it's
still changing
[Music]